I do try to write novels that speak to
speak to reality in some way a little
area of writing exclusively issues books
though I've certainly been guilty of
that I I have strong political opinions
often strong conflicted political
opinions and it's when I feel conflicted
that I know that that I've got a good
subject it's important not to what
fiction degenerate into polemic when
writing about health care you know I
don't want it to sound like a an op-ed
and it's also important that even if you
are writing about NSU and it is an issue
that you have strong partisan feelings
about that there's enough air in the
narrative to allow for those other
points of view that maybe you feel as if
you you you disagree with but you have
to give them a voice if you're going to
explore any kind of an issue with some
dimension as far as I'm concerned the
only thing that makes politics important
is the way in which these issues
translate into individually lived lives
so it has to have implications for
single people what happens to them and
what they feel so in writing about
healthcare I'm not talking about you
know what tax exemptions that I'm
advocating but you know what what is it
like to receive an EOB or explanation of
benefits and try to go through all those
papers and figure out what checks you're
supposed to write and where and you know
this is what people are going through
it even has a comic aspect and that's
you know that can make for good fiction
but again you hit you do have to be
careful you don't want to write a novel
that becomes obsolete know that becomes
an anachronism that's the biggest
problem with speaking to the immediate
moment because the moment is always
moving so if you speak to this moment
and for that matter it takes two to
three years to write a book and then
also to get it get it out so if you
speak to the immediate moment to
specifically it's already moved on by
the time the book is published and you
are told in being in trying to be super
relevant you make yourself irrelevant
therefore it's important to try to keep
consciously addressing issues that never
go away so that in my latest book I'm
talking about larger matters of illness
and what it's like to face death what
kind of an effect a diagnosis of
terminal illness for one spouse has on a
marriage does it bring you closer
because suddenly your time together is
so precious or or does it alienate you
because you're living in completely
different universes and I think the
answer is a little bit of both but these
these deep human things about marriage &
Family and friendship and the experience
of of birth and death aren't going
anywhere they are timeless and if you
don't have some of those elements in
your story then you're going to become
dated in short order
well naturally I draw on people whom I
know and any fiction writer is always
drawing on his or herself and though I
have to admit that in latter years I've
gotten a dead bored with myself I
believe by the way that this is the
healthiest development in um in my
character I think becoming bored with
yourself is it's probably some kind of
Zen achievement but what I really enjoy
about the process of constructing
characters and then I tend to go for
more composites of taking little bits
and pieces from here and there is the
way in which gradually they do achieve
an integrity and identity of their own
which is quite apart from whoever might
have helped to inspire them and that's
when I know a book is working is when
even in my own head that character has
an Independence of the sources that
contributed to that character and that's
when that's when a book starts becoming
fun is that you you know I can start
seeing them I can hear them talk in my
head and you know it's all an illusion
but it's it's it's a delightful illusion
oh yes they definitely stay with me and
the funny thing is I I get easily
offended on their accounts I really
don't like it when a reviewer insults
them and I do believe that this this
experience of how dare you say that
about Shep is distinct from how dare you
say that about me as an author it is a
it is a protective sensation my little
awards right it's like okay you know
they're they're defenseless you don't go
for them you go for me go ahead and salt
me as much as you want but you leave
Shep alone right he's a good man he's a
lot nicer than I am